hey everybody i'm dave from poggingface
and today we have a chat between myself
and dr andrew brock andrew is a deep
learning researcher at deepmind focusing
on fundamental neural network training
efficiency and scalability generative
models and computer vision he's widely
known as being the first author on the
famous big gan paper and was also a
contributor to the receiver and
perceiver i o papers
in this chat we talk about his
interesting journey to becoming an ai
researcher his work on generative models
and where he sees the field of
generative machine learning going
without further ado here's andrew
yes excellent andrew thank you so much
for joining me today um uh we're really
happy to have you here
yeah happy to be here
yeah um so uh one of the first things i
always like to ask people that are into
machine learning is how did you end up
in the field of machine learning
yeah sure so i'm a mechanical engineer
by training my undergrad and first
master's in mechanical engineering i
worked as a controls engineer
and my first thesis was on uh
basically computational fluid dynamics
and heat transfer for aerospike hybrid
rocketry
but a lot of that stuff is very similar
to ml in a lot of ways in the day-to-day
grunge work in the types of things
you're doing basically boiling down to
optimization
some degree of hyper parameter tuning
um and while i was working as a controls
engineer
um i was studying a bunch of different
like controls textbooks being deeply
dissatisfied with what i found with how
much uh the algorithmic
choices i made as a working on controls
didn't really seem to matter much uh
relative to like the actual choice of
hardware the other mechanical things
that i was doing
uh and i stumbled upon like people
talking about oh i trained a neural
network to do this and this is like a
paper from like 1987 or whatever you
know and i've never heard though like
you train a neural a what like what are
what do any of those words especially in
conjunction mean
and then simultaneously with this my
partner
left california where i was studying uh
to do her veterinary degree in glasgow
and so i needed a way to get across the
ocean uh which isn't easy if you don't
have a visa and nobody really wants to
hire mechanical engineers from a
different country let alone a different
continent
because of all visa hassles involved so
i did the easy thing and went and
applied for a phd uh in the closest
realm i could find which is robotics and
by dint of being the only person to
apply for the position i
uh spotted i got the spot which was nice
uh no competition no bar yeah yeah and
then this is around 2015 so this is just
before
things really took off so this is post
alex now but pre-resnets pre-gan or not
pre-gans but pre-dc gan kind of thing
um so this is just around the time when
there were headwinds of like deep
learning's the next big thing mark
zuckerberg is showing up to nurips um
but before things had really become as
deeply saturated and as deeply diffused
as they are now um although even then
people were saying oh it's already
saturated oh the field is completely
saturated at this point you shouldn't
worry and learn too many people
um which i'm sure people will continue
to say for decades to come and maybe now
it's true um
but yeah so then i um my phd is actually
not really in machine learning per se um
my phd is in robotics and most of the
work i was doing there
uh was for industrial applications of
vision um so there is machining in the
mix but it's more about hardcore
computer vision but none of that i was
able to publish owing to the fact that
it was all industrially sponsored so
that's all under ip lock and key for
like five to ten years uh so i kind of
had to do like a separate line of work
in my phd to be able to publish
uh but yeah that was that was the
general path was like mechanical
engineering
uh building stuff and controlling stuff
uh and then like oh just do a phd
because there's no other way to get to
the uk
right yeah you know it's so funny it
sounds like you know you have your
partner to thank for
absolutely bringing you into this field
do you think you would have gotten away
otherwise
no definitely not um i think that i
would have probably like moved to the
bay area and been a mechanical engineer
for the rest of my life otherwise like
my my best friend
uh was going to stanford to do his phd
mechanical engineering working from
national labs i probably would have just
gone with him or he didn't actually end
up at stanford davis um but i probably
would have just hung out with him for
the rest of forever uh so but now you
know i live in london and that's a
completely different path
wow that is that is an absolutely wild
uh a journey there so yeah make sure you
thank your partner i suppose
yeah
she reminds me all the time oh i'm sure
i'm sure i'm sure it's it's all it's all
unheard it's great uh so what kind of
things are you are you working on right
now
yeah so i've been doing a lot of high
risk high reward research over the last
couple years
um and that's why you might notice like
based on my scholar profile if you if
you stalk me um i produce relatively
little output um especially relative to
to certain other people some people
publish quite a lot i tend to publish
very little
um and this is partially based on most
of the things i do never working
but also partially based on having a
pretty high bar for what i want to
publish and sometimes that's a good
thing sometimes it's a bad thing
sometimes there are things i've got that
probably should be like they're worth
publishing they're worth telling people
about but i put a lot of work into
papers and so i choose to hold back or i
choose to chase the next shiny thing
um but yeah so i've been working on a
combination of things i've been involved
with and i can talk about this now are
our large scale language modeling
efforts over the last couple years in
more of an advisory role than uh in a
primary contributor role but i've been
doing a lot of little consulting
projects based on our expertise in
training and understanding stability of
neural networks
um and a lot of these things that we did
uh we basically came up with a bunch of
new like oh an optimizer that has better
properties for the specific things we're
trying to achieve
um layers that are faster for whatever
in certain contexts um but the the thing
that frequently happens in these
situations um especially in like a
strike team driven scenario where you
have a very specific goal that you need
to achieve
is that lots of things work at very
small scales or even at medium to large
scales but as soon as you get past some
certain threshold which there isn't like
a hard number for this it's not like
past 10 billion parameters things become
different um but you kind of enter a
qualitatively different regime of
learning optimization of stability of
just about anything um and
not everything transfers past that point
and it turns out that pretty much most
of the things that i had come up with uh
just like when we finally got the
resources to test them at scale they
didn't quite pan out
um so there's been a lot of a lot of
things like that in the last year
i've been doing a lot of work uh at the
intersection of ethereum practice in
neural fields which has also been in a
similar situation
so this is things like sirens or nerfs
you might hear them referred to as
implicit representations or coordinate
networks
um so i've been doing a lot of work on
that front to make these faster to
better understand theory of training
them theory of stability for these
um but mostly just to try and like find
something to do with them really
nerf is the chronical example but in a
lot of other cases like you fit a siren
to a signal and then you say okay then
why why did you do that what is the
purpose of not having this
representation it's not a very good
compressor it's worse than jpeg
um there's there's a whole lot of things
that you could conceivably do
which don't necessarily work very well
so i've been doing a lot of things like
that
um where basically i'm i'm more
interested in non-incremental research
in the sense of like trying to do
something that at least qualitatively
feels like it hasn't been done before
um and most of my research prior to this
has been in a sense incremental in at
the very least um taking something that
is a you know working on a strong
baseline and then trying to improve that
or
uh and i think there's a huge amount of
value in that i think this is something
where like people say incremental but
they they mean that they take that to
mean small increments but there's a lot
of research which is incremental but the
increment is quite large um i think open
ai in a lot of ways is like a master of
doing things like this which again not
to call the research incremental but to
say that like a lot of the things you
see that come out of there aren't like
completely out of left field they're
based on things that are fairly well
understood but they had an insight or
they cleaned up the method or they did
something they got all the details right
and the paper kind of feels from a
research perspective incremental but
that increment is very very large
right because they take that increment
and they scale it right
yeah yeah well there's also sales and
multiplier on that for sure
um so i'm i've been moving a little bit
away from that i still enjoy that i
think it's a really valuable mode of
research um but i've been trying to do
things especially because i'm working
full-time as a research scientist at
deepmind um you have a lot more leeway
to kind of take risks like that so while
it may not be the best thing for your
career to spend like years down in the
down in the weeds trying to look for
uh something weird or something some
particular gem down there
um you know it's a lot of fun and
there's a lot sometimes you know the
potential rewards are quite high because
that's where you might find you know the
the strange new thing
right that's like that's that's the only
way you like you can only uh find those
things by diving really deep so yeah
yeah
you know uh
kind of going back to uh uh some of that
work that you were doing before uh one
piece of work um uh you're you know your
most prominent piece of work probably to
that most people will know you from is
is your work on big gan which is from
the paper you know large scale again
training for high fidelity natural image
synthesis
for folks that might not be aware can
you talk about what kind of led up to
that work
yeah sure so that paper is definitely a
piece of incremental work
a lot of people are mad about that when
you know there's a lot of people you
just you just make gans bigger and that
is a little that is literally the point
of the paper
um
when uh i've always been interested in
representation learning um this is what
drove me to originally look at gans um
right around the time dc game came out i
was interested in vaes interesting
against normalizing flows
i really liked generative models as an
unsupervised representation learning
paradigm uh they made a lot of sense the
theory behind them was really solid even
if gans have a lot of interesting weird
quirks to them uh theoretically and they
all have substantial amounts of
practical problems you know gans have
such weird instabilities vaes
don't really work very well um flows you
have to maintain invertibility um
diffusion has a lot of interesting
things going on and seems to have a lot
of groundswell for it right now but it
also has certain drawbacks if you're
trying to do certain other things
um and i'll get i'll probably want to
talk about that later because the the
current state of the field is quite
different all right that's one of my
questions so yeah the whole and this is
this well i'll get i have some opinions
on that um but basically i was always
interested in doing like unsupervised
representation learning um because i you
know if you're if you think about like a
path to agi or anything along those
lines which i don't necessarily
always adhere to or
consider that my guiding star
um like it's just it's something where
you think oh you're learning
representations and you don't need to
have a human in the loop you don't need
to have feedback you don't need labels
necessarily that's a really compelling
paradigm for doing this um so i've been
working on generative models for a while
uh and i had figured out a way basically
to learn a mapping from well basically
the word to vex space to a conditional
space that you could use to conditional
uh a generative model uh and i really
wanted to do zero shot image synthesis
which we now are very very good at but
which at the time we were basically i
mean even like
not zero shot text image synthesis we
were very bad at especially like 2017
2018 we basically could not do this um
the results now are are stunning by
comparison
um and i really really wanted to do this
well but i knew that i needed a strong
baseline
and at the time the best thing was uh
basically sn gan or progan so you had
spectral normgan
which is really only going up to like
128 pixels progan went higher but
everything with the program and style
game line of work is very centered
around
very clean data sets you typically have
highly aligned data sets um it's very
difficult to apply stylegan or program
directly to like imagenet or things with
lots of pose variation there has been a
lot of work since then that has overcome
that people are now doing style going on
whatever
just because there's so much
practitioner
um knowledge and know-how that's kind of
led into to making these work
in places where they previously you know
initially might not have um at least
free gan is probably a little bit better
for that in some ways um but i started
building this baseline and i started
with sngan
because that had just come out uh and so
i built this baseline i you know i
ported it over from chainer to pytorch
which is literally the most trivial
thing you can imagine because they're
almost exactly the same or at least they
were at a time
and i started building this out and then
i was going to be starting my internship
with deepmind in may of that year
uh and if you if you ever intern
anywhere for for a research position um
you kind of only you have a very limited
amount of time to do a research project
uh you really want to hit round for
running if you can and ideally you want
strong direction for a bite-sized piece
of research that you can turn into a
paper
um you don't always have this you don't
always have something ready to go at the
time but i knew that i wanted to like do
upfront work uh to be able to be
prepared for for doing this because what
i wanted to do was get on the google
infrastructure re-implement all my stuff
in whatever tensorflow framework was was
hottest at the time uh this would have
been sonnet for us which is i still hold
sonic is the best tensorflow framework
but i i you know i can't stand
tensorflow
and i wanted to just basically scale
that up and say like okay let's let's
take this and let's make it bigger let's
like train it as fast as possible let's
get the highest resolution best baseline
that we can and then we'll start doing
like zero shot image synthesis um and so
it took a while just to like you know to
to code all that up to get that working
and if you ever implement again from
scratch you will know that there is no
way to do it and not get it wrong um you
will always make some silly mistakes
somewhere that leads to your model not
training at all it will simply not work
until you have every single detail right
you should never implement again from
scratch i've done it like five times you
never never do that from scratch
um
and as we were studying this um
attention gam what was it called um
essaygn came out
um and i had access to their code
because they this is really very
important uh so this is a brain
internship project uh and i had access
to their code which they had not yet
released and so i was able to basically
take their architecture and immediately
start using it
this is especially important because
there are actually a bunch of
differences from the paper uh in the
actual architecture that they used uh
that basically
resulted in it being substantially
deeper and wider
than an sn gan which it was supposed to
be and this may not have been a mistake
but in any case um we noticed that like
oh switching to this architecture we
suddenly get slightly better results
like buy and measurable and inception
score fid both of which are pretty bad
metrics but are at least somewhat
correlated with uh image quality um and
then i said okay well we've got some
we've just got tpus online this is just
when tpuv3 uh was coming online and the
fleet had just spun up but nobody knew
how to use them because you needed to
basically run on them in a strange way
the infra for doing this was very raw
um and actually like
there's almost like a papers worth of
work just in the engineering that was
done to make this possible right um most
of it was not engineering work that i
did um but it was we were taking
advantage of this and the fact that
nobody else knew these were around
um and so we started running on tpu and
the number one thing you can do on tpu
very easily is increase the batch size
and i said okay i'm going to double the
batch size from typical 128 256 take
that up to 512. and like the quality of
scores doubled basically when you double
the backside yeah and that's when you
see that happen you might you assume it
has to be a bug there is no situation in
optimization in general and specifically
in neural net training and deep neural
training where doubling the batch size
without any other change in parameters
for an already strong baseline leads to
these kinds of performance improvements
right so you're like you know what did i
what did i do wrong
yeah it was it was kind of insane it was
basically like standing in absolutely
the right place at the right time and
getting lightning strike lucky on top of
that we were we've done the upfront work
to be able to take advantage of this um
we had all the resources coming online
so we could actually you know use that
larger batch size and train these larger
models
uh and then it turned out that like
doubling quadrupling octopusing the
batch size was just like the best thing
you could possibly do it turns out that
we were standing right at the the base
of the mountain when it was time to
scale
and nobody else realized it yet so this
is you'll see this a lot is that someone
notices oh it's time to scale these
things this is something we haven't
scaled before and now everybody's like
looking for the everybody's aware of it
a lot more
um
time nobody had really scaled gams and
obviously this is also conditional on
having access to the kind of compute you
need to do right right um yeah so
basically i spent 20 weeks where i was
supposed to be doing all this text to
image so this is stuff all the zero shot
generative modeling and supervised or
self supervised representation learning
stuff uh and then i just kept building
my baseline and i never stopped i sort
of ran out of time to do any of the
actual research i had planned because
building this baseline was just going so
absurdly well uh that it didn't make
sense to focus on anything else so big
again is just a baseline for like
studying other things
uh that never got around and i never
really had time to study the other
things that i intended to do with it
and then by the time i got back to it
there was other you know by the time
like it's right now right if you wrote a
big game paper right now with those
kinds of results like even working on
gams in 2022 um like it's not it's not
really where the momentum is in research
so it doesn't make as much sense uh to
be focusing on those kinds of directions
but at the time you know it's just like
oh hey this thing is just like crazy
good this thing produces really high res
uh really high fidelity images it still
inherits all the began problems mode
dropping
um mode collapse et cetera et cetera but
yeah that was basically just a baseline
that got out of hand too big
right and as a baseline i've seen it
used as a baseline to compare against uh
these diffusion models uh so yeah like
last week we we saw uh dolly 2 be
announced from open ai which for people
that don't know is a model that is
designed to do text image generation as
well as things like in painting
so
you know unlike the original dolly this
one uses the new ideas like diffusion so
have you been working with any of these
diffusion models recently
not personally i'm attached to some
projects that are i'm peripheral to some
projects that are
um you know we've we've got some
diffusion work uh that you'll see
um but basically uh no i have not been
doing any diffusion work i think that
dolly too especially like it's not
necessarily super duper surprising from
the point of view of like
better better text-to-image results
coming from better progress in this area
but i mean like obviously it is
flabbergastingly good this is absolutely
a monumental achievement and it's a
really interesting example of this kind
of larger trend that we've been seeing
of a very stark move away from the
traditional principles of generative
modeling nobody looks at dali
except maybe like the deep learning
anti-hype crew um nobody looks at dali
and says like oh what's its mode
coverage
how what is it what is its likelihood on
cfar no no one asks that right because
even though those things are they are
interesting to study and they tell you a
lot nobody's going to be looking at the
gnats or the bits per tim on dali the
the same is true of the gpt series of
all the large language models um there's
a quote from an nlp researcher from like
four or five years ago where they said
like why is anyone training language
models something that predicts the next
token
sentence that's not useful it's not
language modeling is not a task
and to some degree that's true but the
weird presence of emergent behaviors or
the ability to you know train these
models in a way
uh that would normally fall under like
oh we care about like traditional
generative modeling and we care about
something else uh and then to use them
for something and actually do things
with them is really quite different from
the almost academic or clinical setting
that they came out of
um so i think that you still see like
everything still has drawbacks right
diffusion has drawbacks scans vaes flows
everything has its own set of uh
benefits and draw max but one of the
number one things you can do with
diffusion
um it's basically this guidance
procedure um you can guide things with
clip and obviously the presence of clip
or other uh just basically language
encoders like this or you know joint
visual visual language encoders it's a
very powerful paradigm for doing text to
image synthesis um the generator in some
ways almost doesn't matter like you can
you can push a lot of generators really
far people have done this with style
game with big game with a bunch of other
things diffusion just is i think better
suited to it it makes a lot more sense
within the diffusion paradigm to guide
it just because you literally have
optimization in the loop
um and you're also slightly less
constrained the presence of basically
global
latency like you do in gans um so your
manifold i think is a lot more free form
and can take a lot more information in
from you know your clip or whatever
you're you're guiding with
um and dolly 2 is just like basically an
incredible example of that of that push
to its limit of that's
done really well really cleanly the
method as described we obviously don't
have all of the details but we have a
fair number um it's very clean
methodologically right it's very it's
very straightforward um it builds on a
lot of their previous work um alex
nicholl and prafulla have done i think
two or three papers previously directly
leading up to this and that's kind of
like this is where they shine right they
take these things and they just get the
details right because the details really
really matter
um and then it's clean and relatively
simple at least at a high level
right and uh
i think i'm really excited uh to see you
know six 12 months from now when when
folks are able to uh recreate these
things in the open so some more folks
can uh uh uh really poke and prod these
models it's really um
interesting now uh i think i'll since we
have like five minutes left or so i
think i'll transition into some personal
questions uh of course i did some
digging on you um
one thing i found was uh this incredible
machine learning pronunciation guide
that was posted to your youtube channel
uh i think i think everybody's wondering
you know uh will there be an update to
this video with any new words that uh
folks might want to hear pronounced
yeah probably not i mean like you know
there there's some of these things are
one and done maybe in the future we'll
see
yeah i think that only has like 100
views so i'm not i don't really care all
that much to be yeah that was a deep
dive i went i hit i hit a
a deep dive on that one now um another
thing i found about you is that at one
point in your life you were a
self-employed dance instructor teaching
ballroom and tango to people of all ages
so how did you get started doing that
i see you found my linkedin yes
yeah um so i used to dance every night
of the week
i started dancing in undergrad um
i went to cal poly in san luis obispo
california uh there's a very at least at
the time there was a very large dance
scene there of uh social dance and you
know like traditional performative dance
um and i just got super involved in that
um i used to run i tried to run track in
college
uh and after about a week uh my injuries
flared and i that obviously wasn't going
to happen anymore
uh so i switched to dancing um and i
just absolutely fell in love with it i
adore
uh pretty much all forms of dance i
primarily dance like salsa and tango um
i did competitive dance sport ballroom
for a while but that has a lot of issues
um and it ultimately wasn't for me but
it's like you know good it's good
training uh and then i just started like
i started the tango club at cal poly
which actually just died a few years ago
but was around for a little while after
me
um and i just started teaching and
getting involved in the community and i
really enjoyed it yeah it's one of those
things where i mean like there's a lot
of things like that where if you get
into the community and it's a tight-knit
community especially in this case it's
very in-person it's very
social and physical exercise kind of
deal
it can be really rewarding it's a lot of
fun and it's good exercise
that kind of dropped off a little bit
for me just with the pressures of grad
school and then as i've gotten older my
injuries have gotten worse so i can't
really dance
uh quite as much as i used to and then
the pandemic hit and social dance is not
something you should be doing with
airborne disease um
people still did and you know there were
there were like dance events people were
running at the height of the first wave
and they all went in and they all came
out with covet alpha and it was like
come on you guys you got it yeah
but
yeah um so i don't do that as much
anymore um there's a you know there's a
great dance scene in london
um really good scenes in the bay area
for a variety of styles um salsa is
pretty much all over the world tango is
too um so also you'll find you know
there's that like people around here
tend to dance like it's called new york
style on two
um in california a lot more people's
dance like la style
um
and i'm a california style dancer so
it's a little bit weird to dance here
sometimes but people people are pretty
flexible right it's great to see you
kind of uh uh you know uh
you're clearly there's something you're
clearly very passionate about outside of
yeah yeah
i do study history of dance um there's
some really great like documentaries on
the history of salsa things like this so
that's i nerd out on that for sure
um
yeah i don't do that as much anymore
though um mostly you know the time and
really injury uh kind of blocks that
now uh outside of research so um and uh
dance and maybe funny youtube videos a
few years ago uh uh what else do you
like to do for fun outside of work
uh yeah i write flan fiction which is
intentionally bad fan fiction uh no um
yeah i'm working on a new one i really
want i really want a um
uh father-daughter romantic not a
father-daughter comedy with ada lovelace
and lord byron where like byron is a
party dad just trying to get her to go
out and and hang out with baton and ada
lovelace is just a computer nerd who
wants to sit at home and solder pcbs and
so if daughter daughter come take come
take a walkabout with lord fancy too no
father i want this model yeah i really i
don't know um
yeah i hang out with my partner um we
play card games sometimes uh i honestly
just work way too much uh but i enjoy
what i do my work is my hobby and i'm
blessed to be in that situation
uh right i think i hear that from a lot
of uh researchers in this field it's
like i think it's something you just
kind of get obsessed with and it
becomes your whole life right because
you're so passionate about it which yeah
yeah yeah it's like i mean like if
you've ever played like satisfying i
don't know like rpg video games where
you have like a progression that you're
trying to achieve
um machine learning offers a lot of the
same kind of dopamine hits because
you're pushing some benchmark um or
you're trying to get a higher you're
trying to get a high score right it's
pac-man
um and there's a lot i feel like a lot
of people are attracted to it for the
same reasons there's a lot of
a lot of things you can do to like you
can measure you can quantitatively
measure your performance relative to
other people you can say i am at the top
of papers with code i am at the top of
the sort of leaderboards
um so there's a lot a lot of those
things and then of course you know it's
very similar to um if you're interested
you know if you if you like to read like
fantasy or different things there's a
lot of things where you're you know you
you're reading for the secrets you're
reading for
or you're playing the game to find out
the secrets but that's kind of what like
science is is that like
there are secrets to life that we don't
know and the only way you can find out
or be the person to find these out first
is to go out there and kind of bash your
head against the wall until uh
either you get a head wound and are
concussed or you break through and find
out what's on the other side
a lot of science is really uh
that's really what makes it compelling
is this idea that you you can be the one
to figure out the next thing even if
it's only a small thing you can you can
discover new knowledge which is
something that typically in your daily
life and most other things is very
difficult to do you don't normally like
like find a new ant oh that's a brand
new app i've never seen before you have
to go looking for them yeah then you can
just name it after yourself you can't do
that
yeah yeah
yeah wow um well i think we're just
about at time i don't want to keep you
too long but
andrew thank you so much for for joining
us today uh this is a lot of fun uh it's
great to hear you talk about uh you know
your work your research and also your
your your passions outside of uh outside
of work um so thanks again for for
joining us
yeah happy to be here
[Music]